allez bertrand installez vous installer
ses comptes pas résisté vous vivez pas
larry ne décrocherait vincent [ __ ]
prochaine de génériques usées partie les
t rex passé bravo pékin express c'est
beau générique c'est parti allez pour
nous les maires des deux mondes
fantastiques énoncé en route pour
l'aventuré
l état bien vertes et des talents dans
un état qui était pas est ce que vous
voulez que je fasse aïda donné le sien
rien non mais ça va partir de la justice
est ce qu'il ya et je suis bien dans sa
va pas vraiment j'ai rien ça ouais mais
moi je suis je suis une flotte à savoir
eh ben ça va s est rien passé on
continue au quotidien
[Applaudissements]
regardez là haut
les amis ou est-il
[Applaudissements]